welcome to the 2014 New York wired store
built out in just over one week this
annual holiday event showcases the
year's best designs for amplifying your
life we're talking about products to
make your tasks simpler faster and more
fun as the hosts of Wired's gadget
challenge we've spent the last few weeks
testing out some of the coolest
technologies from the pages of Wired
magazine so when they invited us to come
check out the New York store in person
we couldn't resist and now on with the
tour
hi guys hey hey welcome to Wired stores
so excited for the tour I'm excited too
let's do it so we're here at the Play
Station what is special about this play
station this is a 20th anniversary ps4
so to commemorate the 20th anniversary
the ps1 coming out Sony released a ps4
in the original grey colorway of the ps1
they only made twelve thousand three
hundred of these because the original
release date was twelve three and
already one of these has sold for twenty
thousand dollars on eBay
so you're saying Eric can't smash it
I would rather he didn't smash it okay I
won't do it so this beautiful vehicle is
this all-electric this one's all
electric is the BMW i3 and this car zero
to 20 is as fast as any other BMW
including all the ends the carbon is
made in Washington with hydroelectric
power the rest of the car is made with
sustainable materials in Germany it's
all carbon neutral smells so sustainable
what's this thing one ring to rule them
all that's what it looks like that's
right it's a ring
Bluetooth interfaces suggest oral
control into your phone you could say
volume up change tracks
that's like Minority Report it's a
little bit like that now these look very
familiar to us because we tested these
on gadget challenge I heard about your
soccer game we're using a ball yes
we're using a sphere oh that would have
been awesome this is like what my
childhood dreams were made of yeah this
is the arcade er this is a beautiful
wood box with like really nice hardware
and about 10,000 games in it from what
all kinds of systems throughout early
game history so here's another product
that we demoed lil bit yeah little bits
but the new cloud bit so the cloud bit
is Wi-Fi enabled and you can connect it
to if this then Matt in this case it's
connected to a little servo motor so we
can feed our fish if we're not around
you can feed your fish on your thumb
from 2,000 miles away yeah or you could
make it so for your team scores a goal
your fish gets food and if not then your
fish dies or you got a bad team your
fish is gonna die it makes the game that
much more intense this is the boosted
board it's an electric power assisted
skateboard it does about fourteen miles
an hour and this is the big thing to
control it not by like leaning like a
Segway but using a wireless handheld
remote I mean I go 14 miles an hour on
my skateboard
anyways that's really my fila my warmup
thanks to Noah and the rest of his team
Eric and I had a blast checking out just
a few of the awesome gadgets at the
wired store
and when day turned tonight wired pulled
out all the stops and through an amazing
VIP opening night party
article one that wraps up our tour of
the New York City wired store it's open
from now until December 21st so if
you're in the New York City area you
should come and check it out but if
you're not in the area you can check out
all these products and much more on
their website store wired comm the wired
store your life better